last time we talked about crypto it kind
of seemed like the good times would just
never end cryptocurrency is going
mainstream Fortune famous the Brave
crypto.com and then they did it's been a
brutal week for crypto investors founder
and CEO sandbagging freed has announced
his official resignation
not only did all these graphs go down
but one of the largest crypto platforms
went bust when we discovered that the
founder was using tons of investors
money to fund his other company and not
telling anyone totally not okay crypto
exchange STX filed for chapter 11
bankruptcy today it's safe to say there
were red flags all over as of last week
it was worth 32 billion surely it had to
be some sort of this is why you're
seeing this guy's face all over the news
lately he literally lost like over 10
billion dollars overnight so now I feel
a bit Vindicated well all of this
turmoil has been going down crypto
actually had a huge win lately something
that no one's really talking about
waiting for the murder it really solved
one of their biggest problems so that's
what I want to focus on today so what
happened and is it enough to save the
crypto verse let's do this the merge is
perhaps the most important update in
ethereum's history can you explain it to
everyone this is the biggest development
of the crypto space most ambitious
change today
hey before we go on I need to pay my
bills and things today's sponsor but now
to that please boy do we have something
good in store today I'm not going to
spoil it but
I should say it took an entire day to
film this video before we get into it I
want to thank today's sponsor which is a
service that we're actually using to
make this video kind of meta thank you
StoryBox for supporting this video check
this out crypto farm
with StoryBots you pay one set price and
then you get unlimited access to all of
this stuff there's over a million assets
on this website and you can download as
much as you want like as much as you
want what I like to do is just download
a bunch of this stuff test it out in my
edit the stuff I use I use the stuff I
don't use I'm not charged for
all right maybe I don't want footage
maybe I want templates
like if you're not an animator but you
kind of want to be an animator literally
you can just download an After Effects
template and you're an animator yeah I
know how to animate but I secretly use
templates all the time it cuts down on
hours of work and they just made a
plug-in for premiere so you could
literally just have storyblocks inside
of your video editor you're pulling
stuff you're not like going and
downloading and moving the file it's all
in Premiere I've been using storyblocks
for literally a decade well before I was
a YouTuber or before they came to
sponsor a video because it's seriously
the best place to find a bunch of really
good stuff for very cheap you pay one
set price either annual or monthly
that's it there's no hidden fees there's
no extra thing and it's a very small
price to pay to take back your creative
control and to have like access to all
of this good stuff so thank you
storyblocks for supporting this video
for supporting my channel there's a link
in my description it's storyblocks.com
Johnny Harris clicking that link
unsurprisingly helps support this
channel but it also allows you to go
learn more about how to get in on this
amazing service thank you again
storyblocks all right let's get into
this crypto video we've got a lot to
cover
okay so before we get into what changed
in the crypto verse which is a very big
deal let's do a little refresher for
those who need it this time with a
little bit of a spin hold on a second
[Music]
welcome to crypto 102.
this is really stupid why am I doing
this every time I have to explain the
blockchain to people I have to do some
gimmick to be like I'm going to teach
you the blockchain using the simplest
version no I'm done I'm not doing it
[ __ ] blockchain
let's do this if you want to understand
why internet money is making the ocean
rise all you really have to understand
is this
[Music]
mining Farm it is a warehouse full of
specialized computers that have one job
and one job only solving math problems
[Music]
these things are all over the world hell
I was in a Swiss bunker a couple weeks
ago and the guy I was interviewing had
one of these things
is this just another way for me to slip
in Switzerland to a video that's
completely unrelated it totally is
any chance I have I will mention my
favorite country anyway these machines
all over the world are sitting here
racing against each other to solve a
complicated math puzzle first and if
you're the lucky computer that solves
one of these complicated puzzles you win
the race and that allows you to verify
what's called a block which is just a
little box of data on the Bitcoin
blockchain for example this block is
only one megabyte of data it's just big
enough to hold like 2 000 transactions
that people have made with their
cryptocurrency as you publicly verify
this block of transactions it gets added
to a long chain of a bunch of other
blocks that have been verified by the
same math puzzle race process
and they sort of get strung together
into a publicly available totally
verified chain of transactions verified
by fancy computers that do a bunch of
math it is called a blockchain wait no
I'm not here to explain the blockchain
I'm supposed to be explaining this
so why would a bunch of people around
the world pay a lot of money to make
these big warehouses so that they can
verify a math puzzle because if you're
the one who owns the computer that
successfully solves the math puzzle and
verifies the block of transactions you
get rewarded in the case of Bitcoin
right now you'd get 6.25 Bitcoins which
is like I don't know nothing more than a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
so yeah there's a huge incentive for
people to build these things and to mine
all day for Bitcoin anyway this race to
complete math problems uses up a lot of
processing power a lot of energy it
takes a whole lot of work for your
computer to run through all of these
computations trying to figure out what
the answer is and that's why this method
is called proof of work every computer
that verifies the transactions on the
blockchain has to do a lot of work
this is all well and cute until you
think through all the energy that goes
into building these machines and then
you think of the electricity it takes to
run them day and night and then you
remember that they get really hot when
they're running all the time doing these
computations so you need to cool them
down with AC units and then remember
that most of the electricity we use
today comes from burning hydrocarbons
which releases a nice thick blanket of
CO2 into the atmosphere that warms the
planet and contributes to the ongoing
global warming crisis
so yeah that's how the math money makes
the ocean rise but that problem may have
just been solved ethereum pulls off the
murder ethereum just got revamped the
second largest blockchain ethereum which
is home to the cryptocurrency ether has
just completely changed the way that it
does the whole crypto electricity math
verification thing this isn't just some
like changing the code and hitting
update this verification process that
they change is like the Beating Heart of
the blockchain switching it out for
something new is like switching out the
engine of a car while it's hurling down
the road at like 120 miles an hour
insanely difficult to do so insanely
difficult to do that nobody else has
ever dared to try it but ethereum they
were like it's worth it for the planet
so they start working on this transition
for years and years they're tinkering
away they're testing it they're
perfecting it until September 15 2022
when they finally flipped the switch and
[Music]
so what happened did it all Crash and
Burn and die and the ethereum blockchain
is no more did the car go hurtling off
the highway without an engine
[Music]
no actually it went off without a hitch
which again for me I'm just like cool
good job guys but the thing that blew my
mind is this
look at this graph I mean look at this
graph this is the energy consumption of
the ethereum blockchain look at that
drop off
we're talking about a 99.5 percent drop
in power consumption for this blockchain
I mean to give you some context here
before this transition which they called
the merge the ethereum blockchain was
consuming the same amount of electricity
as the country of Chile it's as if a
major developed country was suddenly
taken off the planet's Energy bill
the CEO of the ethereum blockchain
claimed that this one software update
has reduced Global power consumption by
0.2 percent which is just like
they did this by changing from the math
puzzle race the proof of work race which
I had to do to verify all their
transactions to a totally different
system called proof of stake so now
instead of having a bunch of computers
Around the World Racing each other all
sucking up energy to do this big math
race now every computer that wants to
verify a block has to put in a stake a
small amount of cryptocurrency that then
puts you in the running to verify a
block sort of like buying a lottery
ticket if you want to win the lottery
you have to make the money to buy a
ticket then through a very complex
process that I will not go into here a
single random computer is picked to
verify that block and take home that
sweet sweet commission so no more of
these big crypto Farms racing against
each other to see who can get there
first contributing the most processing
power instead it's just one computer
during the very light lifting of
verifying a block because again it was
the racing all of these Machines working
simultaneously that used up the power
not the verification process itself so
there you have it the cryptoverse was
saved the power hundred computers were
turned offline and the world energy
consumption plummeted all over the globe
the ice caps stopped melting and the
pollution was reduce their lowest levels
in 40 years
actually that's not what happened at all
and the cryptoverse is far from Saved
peptic Johnny I didn't know you were
going to be here I thought you moved to
Tampa I heard you were making another
video so I thought I'd stop by can I
come in I guess
um
okay
I'm gonna be back
crypto Johnny hey I heard you guys were
talking about crypto and I'm here to
tell you that the cryptoverse might not
be totally saved but this is a huge step
in the right direction I'm coming in
oh gosh why do crypto people always have
to be so polarized can we just stay
curious about this new technology and
just see what happens no no okay fine
let's do this again can I at least get
some Doritos
okay
I thought the video was over okay let's
do this skeptic Johnny you start I
honestly want to hear what you have to
say I thought that the merge in this
huge proof-of-stake thing was like a
huge win for crypto so what's your
rebuttal no I mean you're totally right
having ethereum switch to proof of stake
was a huge deal is a huge deal a
completely like that graph that you
showed earlier super impressive thank
you didn't realize this was gonna be so
amicable but let's be clear that this is
just one of a million problems facing
crypto the crypto space is still Rife
with scams and volatility the real
reason your little project hasn't taken
off yet is because regular old people
are way too afraid of losing their money
with a cryptocurrency that can be worth
65 000 one month and then a couple
months later worth thirty five thousand
dollars word wait well that happened to
me whoa you invest after the last video
when this guy gave his big crypto sermon
I was kind of convinced and things were
going well and so I went and I bought
like a thousand bucks worth of crypto
and now it's worth like 300 yeah case
and point you and like everyone else who
dabbled in crypto you'll make it all
back you just need to hold okay but even
if he does make it back the volatility
of crypto isn't actually its biggest
problem if it's not the environment and
it's not the volatility which I'm
concerned about what is it this ought to
be good it turns out that crypto's
biggest problem is that guy
hey how's it going guys oh God not this
guy wait there's more of you what is
this I don't do this who the hell is
this guy that is Johnny Law and he is
hard at work thinking about how to
regulate crypto the real existential
threat to crypto right now is not
volatility or the environment or the
lack of adoption it is Regulators
No One's Gonna Get that reference unless
they had an older brother who was into
hip-hop in the 90s hey my brother had
that album too love Nate Dogg before you
go into the SEC wait hold on let me just
finish this thought about the government
and Regulators before you can have your
rebuttal the fact is we did see some
governments Embrace crypto like the
government of El Salvador who like made
it legal tender at that same time other
governments were showing what it looks
like when you regulate crypto in China
they've outright banned crypto you're
not allowed to conduct any kind of
transactions in or outside of the
country and you're not even allowed to
mine it totally banned yeah that's cool
but China still accounts for the second
most mining activity in the world it's
almost as if I don't know the rise of
the cryptoverse is inevitable okay
governments be damned you may actually
get a front row seat to see how
Unstoppable the crypto versus is because
the United States may be next no no
you're getting it all wrong me and the
USA we're chill we love crypto in the US
it's all about Freedom it's all about
doing what you love okay me and Matt
Damon were like best friends fortune
favors the brave yeah but Matt Damon
doesn't pass regulations in the United
States the SEC does wait wait I know
that one sec Security and Exchange
Commission right yes great work
the real Johnny's real smart
but yes that is correct the SEC is a
thing in the United States that is meant
to protect investors just don't get it I
mean look at this article that I have
here from the head of the SEC that wrote
it in the Wall Street Journal wait did
you actually print off that paper yes I
printed it out it helps me read it I'm
dyslexic you have an issue with that I
didn't I didn't say that dude I'm just
subject too and I love printing things
especially in Big Font thank you anyway
head of the SEC writing in the Wall
Street Journal guess how many times he
mentions the environment I mean here you
look at it
does that article mention anything about
the environmental concerns of crypto
hold on I'm checking here I'll just tell
you it doesn't the SEC doesn't care
about the environment that's the EPA the
SEC cares about one thing protecting
Americans from being scammed so yeah it
is amazing that the ethereum blockchain
was able to get off of its insane energy
consumption that is a great step but the
cryptoverse is still riddled with the
same old problems it's always had the
problems that the SEC is rearing to sort
out with a bit of good old regulation
he calls are being renewed for oversight
and legislation from Congress but wait
they're not going to like ban crypto in
the U.S like this isn't China right ha
yes thank you this is all overblown I
mean yeah they're not gonna ban it
completely you're totally right but they
could reclassify crypto as a security
instead of a commodity right Johnny Law
I mean yeah theoretically I could yeah
I'm gonna be honest I don't know what
that means basically what this means is
that crypto would now be registered with
the SEC like ethereum would have to
register ether and all other
applications with the government yeah
that doesn't sound great for the whole
untraceable unregulated crypto Utopia
philosophy no it doesn't okay okay
you've talked with all your nerdy
regulation stuff this is 100 speculation
there's no proof that they're actually
gonna do this and besides even if they
do a regulated but still decentralized
monetary system is a lot better than a
regulated centralized one like the one
that we have with banks I am so glad you
brought that up oh this is getting good
so let's talk about decentralization
it's one of the main pillars of the
whole crypto project right yeah
obviously great then you'll be
interested to know that since they did
this big merge this big flip to proof of
stake almost half of all transactions
now happening on the ethereum blockchain
are taking place from two addresses only
two two addresses so much for
decentralized yeah but the fact oh wait
I'm not done yet one sec I just need to
say one more thing which is all of those
Farms that I'm telling you about that
are now like defunct and obsolete do you
really think those people are just gonna
like pack up and go home and be like
well we have no use for our like
hundreds of expensive computers and
Mining farms in Iceland no they're just
gonna switch to another blockchain that
can use their computers to do the same
old thing that they've been doing
forever which is mining blockchain
through proof of work that energy
consumption isn't disappearing it's just
being transferred holy [ __ ] sorry sorry
but a couple weeks ago I was in
Switzerland is there ever going to be a
video where you don't mention
Switzerland seriously dude no of course
not but anyway when I was in that Swiss
bunker which was right around the time
that this merge was happening it was
like the end of September they told me
that they were shutting down their
mining operation for a little bit just
last week he says he's not making money
right now so I'll take a break and it
must have been because of the merge cool
and their next step was to just like
destroy all of those really expensive
computers and revamp the bunker to be
some hip Airbnb is that what their plan
was I mean no they're probably just
looking for like other blockchains to
like use all their Hardware on yeah
exactly it was sort of a rhetorical
thing I didn't know you were going to
actually try to answer the question
um it was kind of embarrassing okay I'm
gonna cut you off there because it's my
turn to speak okay you've been just
blabbering this whole time so yes a lot
of these miners are moving to other
blockchains to use their big mining
Farms but this is just the beginning
this is early days do you realize all
Technologies start out clunky you want
to hear my prediction the biggest effect
isn't the big graph that goes down to
zero of all of its energy consumption
it's how it's going to Inspire other
blockchains to do the same thing to
adopt proof of stake like imagine if the
Bitcoin blockchain adopted proof of
stake it would change the world it would
literally change the world but that's
never going to happen Bitcoin has zero
plans to switch to proof of stake or any
other way of verifying and unlike
ethereum which is run like a business
they have a CEO they can actually make
these decisions top down Bitcoin is this
super decentralized project you would
need 51 of the users to all agree to
switch something this big it's not going
to happen anytime soon but they might
not have a choice if the rest of this
master plan that ethereum has goes as
smoothly as the merge then it's going to
be more of a case of adapt or die wait a
plan what are you talking oh you haven't
heard the merge is just the beginning oh
man buckle up for this one after the
merge we have the surge then The Verge
then The Purge then the Splurge really
the Splurge why do these tech companies
always have to come up with these cutesy
naming things The Surge is just the next
part of the master plan it involves
massively scaling up the ethereum
blockchain which is way easier to do now
that we have proof of stake verification
okay so you're probably asking what
would this scaling up even do I actually
didn't ask it would mean instead of the
ethereum blockchain being able to
perform like 20 transactions per second
it would be able to perform over a
hundred thousand transactions in a
second guys this is huge don't even get
them started on the verge yada yada yada
I feel like this is just another set of
empty words to get people excited so
they invest in the math money project
that you're doing every time we talk
about crypto it seems like it always
goes to this some like life-changing
world-changing technology that's just
right around the corner if we all just
believe it just feels like yet another
stop along the crypto hype train and I'm
not here for it okay okay I think I'm
gonna call it there guys but Johnny I
wanted to talk about The Verge zip it
crypto Johnny I'm shutting it down okay
we've had enough you can talk about The
Verge when initiative I make another one
of these videos in like six months
because apparently that's what I do now
for now let me just say this
the merge was indeed an incredible
technical feat it was a huge Boon for
the environment I mean that graph is
insane this is going to be a great thing
for the planet no matter what but will
it save the crypto verse alone probably
not there are way more trials and
tribulations to overcome this technology
is barely a decade old we don't have to
have these strong opinions on either
side the reality is none of us know
what's gonna happen next so why don't we
all just agree to sit back relax and see
what happens next nope not gonna happen
he says the same thing every time the
goods all hold hands and be friends no
okay I give up whatever do you guys want
to go to beer or something I've actually
been super into hard kombucha lately of
course you have yeah I actually know a
great place down the road let's go okay
let's go let's do it
foreign
[Music]